Thank you very much for giving me the
opportunity to talk with you guys today.
So, um, yeah, I'm a computational
astrophysicist. So you know,
my day job is not thinking about aliens.
Um, they've kind of my night job.
So my day job is studying things like
how stars form and how planets evaporate.
I do a magneto fluid, large
scale supercomputer Nitos, uh,
fluid dynamical simulations
of astrophysical cas dynamics.
But because I do a lot of work with the
public, you know, I've been thinking,
I've ended up having to think a lot
about climate change cause I write about
climate change, um, and
over the years, you know,
I've had to deal with a lot of climate
denial and that is unbelievably
frustrating. And in deal doing that, um,
I came to start thinking about the
problem differently about how, you know,
ways of the ways in which we frame
climate change entirely wrong.
Um, and so that's really what
the, the topic of my book
is. So light of the stars,
Alien Worlds and the fate of the earth.
Uh,
so what I want to take you through
is kind of a different perspective on
thinking about climate change,
um,
from what I would call the
astrobiological perspective.
So the idea here is you can't solve a
problem until you understand it and you
can't understand it until
you can tell its story.
And my premise here is that the story
we're telling about climate change is the
wrong story.
And it's not our fault,
it's just that we're in a different
position now and we can tell a different
story. And the story we're trying to tell
about, uh, the, the, is the human future,
what is the human future on
a climate changing planet.
But in some sense,
really what I'm asking you is what does
the future for any civilization, um,
a large scale industrial
civilization on any planet?
I'm going to take you through why
that's not a crazy question to ask. Um,
so the problem we know is
climate change, right? That, uh,
the Anthropocene anthropogenically
driven a change in the planetary state,
um, that we are switching from a state
for the last 10,000 years that's been
basically warm and moist. Uh, meaning
most of the stuff isn't a lot.
Most of them are not most but lots
of the waters and locked up in ice to
something, um, that we don't know, right?
We're pushing the earth into a new state.
And then there's also a couple to this
are issues of resource depletion from
freshwater to forests. Um, so you know,
this issue of sustainability comes up,
right? Can we build a sustainable
version of our planet?
And when we think about
science and politics, right?
Cause that's somehow whenever we
want to have this conversation,
that immediately falls
into the political domain.
And while certainly policy is a pillow,
you know,
there's going to be politics to science
itself is what gets cast suddenly
becomes political. And when you think
about this, it's really amazing.
And when I did the research for
this book, I realized that, um,
or I found that actually a president
in 1965 gave a speech to Congress
identifying CO2 and climate change
as a potential problem, right?
So the idea that somehow this is
this modern hoax that, uh, you know,
climate denialist wanted to tell
you about is this gives lie to it,
that know in 1965 actually that should
be President Johnson gave a speech before
Congress where he, you know, uh,
mentioned CO2 as a and the climate
change as a particular problem.
But so we know what's happening now is
this political polarization that somehow
this science issue got lumped into all
the other kinds of polarization that we
have. So if you have a certain
set of beliefs for some reason,
you also have to think that climate
change is a hoax or climate change isn't
happening.
Um,
and that's part of the dilemma we face
and trying to take any action on the
problem. So what is the
real problem? You know,
what is the real problem that we're
facing? Um, and it's really one of a,
a perspective,
not politics because the science right
has been settled for a long time.
My first job after undergraduate,
I took a year and a half off and I did
lots of crazy things like planting trees
in British Columbia. I was a bouncer at
the rocky horror picture show on the,
the eighth street playhouse in New York.
But I also got a job in 1985 add, um,
Jim Hansen's Goddard Institute for Space
Studies. And you know, I asked them, yeah,
it was a programmer, basically a
scientific program. And I said, yeah,
what are we doing here? And
they said, Oh, you know,
we're studying to see whether or not
the climate is going to be changing.
That's an idea we have. And
I was like, whoa. Right.
So this was 1985 long before anybody
else had heard of it. By 1988,
Hanson gives that very famous,
uh, uh, testimony in front
of Congress saying like,
look, we actually have found the signal.
So the, you know, the science is old.
And so the science is not the problem.
It's the perspective that's the
problem and our perspective.
And I think the reason we have
such a hard time, uh, you know,
the public and I deal a lot with the
public and for my science writing is that,
um, we think it's a onetime story. We
think we are a one time story, right?
We think climate change is something
happening to us and you know,
that's the only time it's ever happened
and there's no guides, no examples,
no other no way of framing this that
allows us to see something deeper in it.
So a, so all we ended up doing is fighting
about whether it's happening or not.
Okay. So what I'm going to argue in
the book is that we have to broaden the
perspective to truly understand,
uh, what is truly happening.
That's the basic idea here.
So what I mean by that is we must
learn to think like a planet.
And that is something that,
you know, over our history,
our 10,000 year history of civilization,
we'd never been called upon to do before.
And by civilization,
what I mean is agriculture city building,
right?
Clearly human beings have
been around longer than that,
but it's in the post hole a scene or that,
you know,
after the ice it last ice ages
and did not post Holocene.
But after post ice age that,
you know, we built this kind of,
we started building this kind of
civilization and it's only now that we,
the planet is starting to notice that
we're here and in order to deal with the
problem, we're going to have to start
thinking the way a planet thinks.
And what I want to argue is we've only
learned how to do that in the last 20
years or so for a bunch of reasons.
Okay. So a little test, um,
which of these is the earth,
but is it all of them? All of them. Yeah,
that's right. That's exactly the question.
I, Oh yeah, I'm going glad when
people see that. Right? So, you know,
the idea here is here's six
different earths, right? That this,
this one is the earth. Uh, and in
the Hadean right after it was formed,
it was a liquid magma ocean.
Uh,
this is a version of the
earth that was a waterworld.
It took a while for the continents to
grow. So when you, when you see those,
you know, animations of the
continents sliding all around,
those only go back a few,
a hundred million years or so.
Because in the beginning all we had were
what were called Creighton's. They were,
it took a while for the continence
to grow. So earth was a waterworld.
There were periods when the planet has
been so warm that's had been virtually no
ice anywhere on it.
So we've been a jungle world.
There's been periods when the
earth has been a snowball,
basically glaciated almost from top to
bottom or from a pole to the equator.
Here's the earth. We have the happier
as we know now. And here is the earth.
You know,
it actually not all that long and maybe
another 2 billion years or so that as
the sun heats up, like any main
sequence star, we'll do, um,
the temperature is going to get high
enough to push the earth outside of the
habitable zone. So the point here is that
there earth has worn many masks, right?
And we need, you know, what,
what's happening with us now is we're
changing the mask that the earth is about
to wear. So we should get used
to this. Um, and it should
become part of our story.
Now, you know, the earth. So as I said,
the earth has had worn many
masks because I love this a,
a diagram that I'm a friend
of mine or a guy I know,
I knew drew just a beautiful
representation of all the
different eras and epochs
and eons of the Earth's history.
And you see all of the different times
and the different kinds of animals.
But what's important is we're up
here in the whole scene, right? And,
and each of these different
earths represents wildly
different conditions that
the planet has passed through.
Okay.
But what we have been living in the last
10,000 years with geologically is not
that long,
is the whole scene.
And here's a record of temperature and
there's zero. This is variations from, uh,
from the current average.
And here's ice content. Well,
you can see as the ice has been
going up and then down, up and down.
And these periods when the temperature
is sort of pokes above zero is these are
interglacials.
So the whole scene,
which is the entire history of human
civilization as just the latest,
uh, latest interglacial. So the
whole of human civilization,
while our history or our wars and hardship
and creativity has been in the whole
scene. But if you look at
the earth's history overall,
and this is one of the revolutions I'm
going to talk about that we've undergone
in the last 20 or 30 years,
that give us this new
perspective on what's happening
to us with climate change.
You see how dramatically life and it
has played a role in these transitions.
So what, here's another question.
These the only two, I promise,
the only to test questions.
What would happen if you landed on the
earth about 3 billion years ago and
walked out of your space ship?
What's the first thing that would happen?
You'd suffocate for it. Good.
Because you know what's amazing,
even though the earth
had lots of life on it,
lights had been on the
earth for a billion years.
There was no oxygen in the
atmosphere, right? The oxygen.
It was a, it was a pure,
almost a nitrogen co two
atmosphere. Um, and uh, the, um,
most of the,
uh,
oxygen got put in place around 2.5 billion
years ago in what's called the great
oxidation event. So this is a plot
of oxygen concentration versus time.
And you can see the oxygen content was a
million times less than it is today. Uh,
back then,
even though the earth we had was rich
with life and what created the great
oxidation event, it was
blue, green bacteria.
There was the invention of a new kind
of photosynthesis that used water as a
substrate and burped out or Fart it out
depending how you want to look at it,
a fart it out,
oxygen,
thereby changing the atmosphere of the
entire planet and changing the entire
evolutionary, um, uh,
history. The evolutionary
trajectory from that point on,
not just for life though, it
had huge consequences, right?
You couldn't have big brains that like
we have without the energy that comes
with oxygen metabolism,
but also for the planet itself.
By having all this oxygen and completely
changed the chemical cycles that
regulated the planets. Uh, you know,
uh, um, uh, the planet's history,
for example,
it created ozone without an ozone layer.
You could never do without ozone.
You would completely change the
dynamics of the surface from the life's
perspective. Without ozone,
you could never have colonized
land. So it was, it was,
uh,
the,
the step and the great oxygenation event
that actually allowed the land to be
colonized.
So this is an example and it's something
very important for us now that life is
constantly co evolving with the planet,
right?
So this is a,
in this plot,
what we see is on this side is things
that have happened in Earth's history
going back 4 billion years and things
that have happened in life's history.
And you see,
there's this constant feedback between
them where the development of a methane
eating bacteria will drive,
um, uh, uh, the great,
uh, uh, snowball, a snowball
phases of the earth's history.
Um, having oxygen allowed sex actually
to happen because it created a,
allowed you to organisms to figure
out, um, sexual reproduction.
So life and planets co evolve.
That should be a lesson for
any life on any planet, right?
What we've seen is that the biosphere,
uh,
is an important actor in the history
of our planet and we should expect that
should be a, a, an important actor in
at least other, some other planets.
So this leads to what is called the Gaia
hypothesis, which has, is very, well,
it's controversial,
but let me tell you a little about it.
It was proposed by James Lovelock in
1979 and the idea was that all living
things on earth kind of
function as a super organism,
that that creates some self
regulates the planet for, um,
the for life, right?
That basically, you know,
even though the sun is
increasing in temperature,
the feedback loops created by particularly
microorganisms will regulate the
planet's temperature to keep it cool
even though the overall solar radiation
that's hitting your planet is going up.
Um,
and this was actually an incredibly
important idea here is, uh,
it was Lovelock and the famous
biologist Lynn Margulis,
who got together and sort
of really built this.
And it was a very controversial
idea when it was first proposed.
And part of that, because it became
kind of a new age sort of, you know,
there were guys in churches and they
were guiding, you know, a festivals.
It became a very new age,
woo idea.
And there was one reason why
scientists didn't like it though.
Well it's because of the idea
of teleology. It's somehow
seemed like an implied,
like the earth wanted to go somewhere
like the earth had a mind and it was
trying to, you know, direct
itself for some purpose.
And of course we know that
evolution is blind, right?
But over time, both, you know,
Margulis and Lovelock, we're able to
show that there's no teleology here.
These are,
this is still blind evolution,
but that these feedbacks do in fact work.
And so what happened was people kind
of dropped the name Gaia and it became
earth systems science. We talk,
we now don't talk about Gaia.
We've talked about the
couple of earth systems.
And by that we mean the biosphere,
uh, the, uh, atmosphere,
the hydrosphere, which is all
the water, the cryosphere,
which ends up playing a huge role,
all the ice and then the lithosphere.
So what we now understand is
that the earth is this very
strongly coupled system,
a couple of systems,
they all interact and that life
is been driving a lot of this, uh,
evolution for quite a long time.
So that was really the main result of
Gaya was to get scientists to understand
that life is not some green scruffed
the sitting on the surface passively,
that it hijack the planet a long time ago.
And when we think astro biologically,
this is a key idea for us as we
go hunting for other biospheres.
So right now there's an
enormous amount of work,
some of it going right on over at Mit,
um,
developing models of so biospheres and
they're using these kinds of ideas as the
fundamental way we're going to
detect life on other planets.
We're going to look for
signatures of biospheres,
chemical signatures of biosphere
is, it's a very guy, an idea. Um,
and actually goes back to Lovelock in
1963 he actually proposed that idea. So,
so this leads us now to the Anthropocene,
right?
So now we have some background here about,
you know,
about life and coevolution and planets.
We come back to ourselves,
which is our entry into the anthropocene.
So the idea of the Anthropocene,
it was first proposed by crucial and
Stromer in 2002 and they were thinking in
terms of strata, they were
actually proposing that, you know,
a million years from now you would be
able to see the earth's entry. You know,
our, our presence by a layer of strata
that would have Kevin Cole or isotopic
signatures of our presence.
But even more than that,
it was the recognition that human
beings now are the, are the drivers,
the principle drivers of changes in
those coupled planetary systems. Right?
And this has now been verified in multiple
ways. Things like we can, you know,
it's human beings who move around
most of the phosphorus on the planet.
Climate change is an obvious example.
Land colonization. There's many,
many markers you can find to show that
really it's human beings that are driving
how this system behaves, which
means we're pushing it, right?
So the climate or the,
those couple of systems,
it's nonlinear complex system right now
it's been sitting at the bottom of a
well, right? You know, in
potential energy, so to speak.
And now we've been rocking it hard
enough over the last hundred and 50 years
that we're now, you know, it's starting
to roll off into some other states.
So the Anthropocene is something
that is happening. Um, uh,
and the question is what are its outcomes
and do its outcomes include us, right?
So the entry into the Anthropocene,
racist,
profound new questions about the
nature of human activity, uh,
within the couple of planetary systems.
And what I want to show is how by
taking this large, this 10,000 light,
your view of this, we actually
gained a pretty powerful, uh,
new way of talking about climate
change. One of these is, I just had an,
an New York Times op Ed, uh, two days
ago about this is that, you know,
this is not about saving the earth.
The earth is going to be just fine.
Thank you very much. Right? So this is,
this whole often gets framed as like, oh,
climate change, we have to
save the planet. Um, but I'd
say I like to say, you know,
the planet is not a little furry bunny.
That's one of the lessons
of understanding. Um, uh,
the earth history. You know,
there are five known mass extinctions.
Each one opened up new
niches for species to evolve,
including like this little critter here
who's, you know, your ancestor, right?
This was a mammo that was around during
the time of the dinosaurs and it was
only the mass extinction
that allowed, you know, uh,
she and her progenitors to lead to us.
Okay.
So even though we're driving
a mass extinction, you know,
in terms of the longterm history
of the earth, the planet,
we'll just use though
that for, um, uh, for a,
for a new round of evolutionary
innovation. So when we
talk about sustainability,
what we have to be very careful is to
understand what are we trying to sustain,
right on. What are the moral imperatives
that we invoke for doing so. So often.
For example, you know, we show
these pictures of, you know,
polar bears on lonely ice flows
to, you know, to, you know,
drive some guilt and some, you know,
and some action hopefully. But,
but the idea is there, you know, when
we think about this is that, oh my God,
we can't let the polar bears go extinct.
But on the other hand,
who's crying for this guy? Right? You
know, the velociraptors were once around,
you know, and they went extinct. Lots
of species have gone extinct. Okay. So,
you know, we need to understand what
exactly were we trying to sustain.
Is the polar bear for itself or is it
the sort of our framing inside the eco
inside the biosphere? I need to, to
make something very clear. Right?
Cause at this point, some people
will get really angry with me. Like,
we don't care about polar bears
do care about polar bears. Right?
But the polar bears get fit into this
larger question, which we're not asking.
So for sure climate change is an immediate
and possibly existential threat to
the project of civilization.
It is imperative that we act immediately
and you know, with, with some, uh,
force in order to deal with it. So
nothing I'm saying here takes that away.
But the problem is,
one problem is why haven't we acted right?
W Y after a gears and Johnson brought
this up, why haven't we acted?
And part of my argument here is that
we've had the story we've been telling us
has been able to be co-opted.
You know, the story,
the main story we've been telling has
been co opted by climate deniers as a way
of blunting, um, our activity.
So what are we trying to sustain,
sustain what we really are trying to
sustain, sustain, if we're being honest,
is the climactic conditions that
are amenable to a particular kind of
civilization hours, right? It's
technological, it's energy intensive.
It's got a pretty high population.
I mean,
hopefully we can bring the
population slowly down,
but unless somebody wants to volunteer,
you know, to off themselves, you know,
it's going to have a high
population for a while.
And also what we want is
maximum human wellbeing.
Actually what we want, you know,
you can add to this maximum biospheric
wellbeing, including polar bears, right?
But we have to understand that really
what we're trying to do is we're trying to
hold some version of the whole scene,
right? We are, we are preferencing,
uh, preference, having prayer,
great preference for the whole scene,
right?
And we have to understand why
we're doing that. So, you know,
we should be honest about why
we're doing that. And as the amp,
as the anthropocene goes on,
one of the things I'm saying is what
you're going to be holding is a version of
the whole scene.
It's not the Holocene anymore
because we're here and
we're going to have impacts.
Um, so by sustaining the
Holocene in perpetuity,
we take on the role of planetary stewards.
And what does that actually mean? Um,
what does that make us? How do we fit
into nature? In particular, right? Um,
in some sense the view I'm advocating the,
uh, city is no different from a forest,
from the biosphere's perspective,
right?
We are what the biosphere
is doing right now. Okay.
So m and a particularly what is nature
in a planet that has a technological
civilization on it, a large scale, energy
intensive technological civilization.
What is nature, what, what
counts is nature anymore. Um,
so now I want to come to, you know, the,
this will be the second half of the talk,
the astrobiological perspective,
how actually thinking
about planet generically,
which is what we should be doing because
that's what we've learned over the last
20 or 30 years. Um, uh,
how does this change,
how does this reframe everything
I've just been saying?
So astrobiology is a relatively new
fields about thinking about life and its
planetary context.
It's about thinking about what's happened
here and what might happen elsewhere
in a deeply scientific and deeply, um, uh,
interdisciplinary kind of way.
Okay.
So there's been three revolutions that
have happened in astrobiology, um,
that we want to address.
And you know,
so clearly astrobiology right now
has an n equals one problem, right?
We only have one example of
life. And you can say like, well,
how do you even have a field when
you only have one thing to study?
The thing is though,
that if you take that point of view,
you're missing some amazing
things that have happened, right?
So it's a very data rich field in
the sense of these three revolutions,
the discovery of exoplanets,
the exploration of our own solar
system and the unpacking earth,
4.5 billion year history. So very quickly,
let's sort of look with those are.
So number one, exoplanets. So
when I was a graduate student,
there were no other planets in
the universe except our own right.
This question of exoplanets dates back,
you can see the Greeks arguing about it,
right? So, um, uh, uh,
Aristotle felt that, uh,
the earth was the only world of its kind
in the entire universe. Um, and, um, uh,
you know,
other Greek thinkers,
the alchemists in particular were very
sure that the universe was full of
planets and all those planets had life.
You follow through history and you can
see sort of people switching back and
forth.
By the 19 hundreds,
it was thought that planets were very
rare because the way they thought planets
would form is that the only,
the only way you could get it was two
stars passing close to each other and
getting gravitational IX, you know,
extrusion like Taffy. So those,
those collisions would be so rare that
it was thought that planets, you know,
one in a trillion stars would
have planets around it. And,
and so this went on until 1995 we
discovered our first exoplanet. Right?
And that was,
that was,
it's not often that you get to live at a
time when a 3000 year old question gets
definitively answered. Since then,
something remarkable has happened,
which is particularly the Kepler mission,
which uses transits when you look for the,
uh,
the planet passing in front of the star.
So the light dims a little bit that
now suddenly we went from, you know,
sort of a retail planet hunting
to wholesale planet hunting.
And so now what we know
remarkably is that every star,
pretty much every star you see in the
sky has a family of worlds around it.
I mean,
that is a remarkable,
planets are everywhere other than
perhaps the most massive stars,
which themselves are very rare.
Every star has planets.
And if you count up five stars,
one, two, three, four, five,
one of them is going to have a planet
in the right place for life to form.
It'll be what's called the habitable zone,
where liquid water can form.
And then we think water
is essential for life.
So one out of every five is in the
right place for life to form. Okay.
So that was one revolution.
The other revolution was,
you know, we've sent robots,
robot emissaries,
now,
robot ambassadors to pretty much every
kind of body in the solar system,
asteroids, comets. We visited
every planet in the solar system.
We've had rovers rolling around,
you know, at least one of them. Um,
but we'd had stuff's Tut that
touchdown a lot of others.
And so we get pictures
like this, which, you know,
could be Mars or it could be the Mojave
desert. Turns out it's Mars, right?
But we've now, you know, we,
this has been a decades now that we've
been rolling around on Mars and we've
learned amazing things.
For example,
we now know for sure that Mars
was a blue world, you know,
and the early part of the solar system,
Mars most likely looked like this. It was,
had a much thicker atmosphere. It
had water, you know, you know, uh,
at least lakes if not oceans on it.
There's a strata that we can
see that you can estimate a,
you can do the estimate to show that
water would probably hip deep was rushing
it about three feet per second, um, uh,
across that channel. So it's remarkable.
So it shows us, especially in dealing
with climate, is to show people that,
you know, it's not like we just have the
earth to study when it comes to climate.
We have tested our climate models
against Mars, against venous,
against Titan,
and those models all I can predict the
weather on Mars basically tomorrow with
great accuracy,
right?
So the idea that these climate models are
just kind of always something somebody
made up, that's, you know,
it's just completely wrong.
We know how climate works because
we've seen how climate work now,
the climate works now on, you know,
six different kinds of planets.
All very different. So, uh, our
study of the solar system has it,
that's what's taught us to think
like a planet, or at least gave us,
taught us how to think like
a planet without life, right?
And then through the earth study, we're
able to think like a planet with life.
Um, what's also important is to show that,
you know, sustainability is just like,
habitability is probably
going to be a moving target.
We're going to have to learn to think
that way because the march used to be
habitable, but it's certainly isn't
now except for maybe, you know,
just very extreme of file
kinds of creatures. Okay.
So that was revolution number two.
And then revolution number three,
as I kind of already went through
is the unpacking of Earth's history,
the great oxidation event, the, um, uh,
the thermal maxima that have occurred
when the planet was a jungle world,
the snowball earth.
We now really have seen that
earth is so many different habits,
has been so many different planets that
in some sense it gives us all those
different areas.
It's almost like we've got nine different
planets with life to study by studying
the Earth's history because they
were so different. So we're,
what does all this lead us? Well, um,
by using the astrobiological perspective,
we can think about the anthropocene and
a broader planet or broader context.
And then this question comes up,
right? Which nobody ever asks.
We all know that we have to build a
sustainable version of civilization,
but how do we know that's even possible,
right?
How do we know that something the
universe does, the universe has,
makes black holes,
universe makes comments,
universe makes interstellar
clouds of a gas?
How do we know what makes longterm
sustainable versions of energy intensive
civilizations,
right?
Because it may be that there's just no
such thing like that in the universe.
So this, by framing it this way,
suddenly, you know, we get, uh,
we're going to ask the questions in
a very different way. But of course,
obviously it means taking exos
civilizations seriously, right?
And I'm using exos civilizations rather
than aliens for a particular reason,
right? So now when I say this,
I'm not talking about detection.
I'm not talking about going out
and finding them though. You know,
that is definitely an interesting thing,
particularly in the era that we're in
when we have all these new exoplanets. Um,
I'm not talking about the
details of their biology,
whether they look like reptiles where
they have nine fingers on each hand,
you know, uh, what kind of sex they have.
That's just like, that's not a medium.
There's no,
I don't have any constraints
scientifically that
actually addressed that. Um,
and certainly not sociology or they
communist capitalist peace loving not,
you know, there's just nothing I can
do there. What I can do, however,
is I can focus on the coevolution of
civilization and a couple and coupled
planetary systems in a scientific way.
I now know enough to run models of this
interaction and ask what the generic
response of a planet is when it's got
an energy intensive civilization. Okay?
And that's what I'm going to convince
them to show you a little bit of those
results.
We've run those models,
just actually publish them just a little
while ago. Right? But so, you know, my,
my emphasis here is it's really time to
start doing this because it matters for
us. And that means it's time to take
[inaudible] civilization seriously.
And it's time to stop snickering about it,
right?
Because anytime you try and bring up
aliens, it's always like, you know, uh,
and that was a long time in
the scientific community.
It's because of prosthetic foreheads,
right?
The reasons we can't talk
about it's aliens seriously
is because we've had years
of bad television science fiction where,
you know, everybody looks like us,
but they've got maybe
antenna on us. So, you know,
we're in a different universe now,
right?
We recognize the civilization that we've
built is the kind of alien civilization
we've always been dreaming of on a
certain level. Right? So, so, you know,
we need now to get past the snicker
factor and ask because that's our own,
it's related to our own, you know,
survival in some sense. Okay.
So what am I telling you now for
the next 10, 15 minutes is a,
we're going to head towards a
science of exos civilizations. Okay?
Theoretical studies that are relevant to
the anthropocene. So first of all, uh,
we have to recognize when we
think about Ekso civilizations,
it's always been a battle between
optimists and pessimists, right?
If you look at the history of this field,
and what I'm going to argue is that
it's not that that changes significantly
with the new data. So I'm sure many of
you are familiar with the Drake equation,
right?
So a long interesting history.
The Drake equation was basically a way
of figuring out how many civilizations
exist right now that we
could communicate with.
And they did that by breaking up the
problem into a bunch of different pieces.
The number of stars in the galaxy,
the number of the fraction of
those stars that have planets,
the number of those planets
in the palatable zone, um,
the fraction of those
planets that form life,
the fraction of that life
that goes on to intelligence,
the fraction of that intelligence
that develops technology. And finally,
as I like to call it, the final
factor, bump, bump, bump, boom,
the average lifetime. That's actually
the thing we're really interested in.
What is the average lifetime of a
civilization like ours? Okay. So, um,
I won't go into this in detail,
but in a paper that we did
in a couple of years ago, um,
woody Sullivan and I use the Kepler data,
right?
We've got all this data about planets now,
which we didn't have before and we
used it to sort of figure out, well,
what can you say about exos civilizations
empirically based on all this new data?
And what we found is that if
you asked the right question,
you could say something pretty
remarkable. Um, so here's what we could,
we define something we
called the pessimism line
and it answers the following
question.
What does the probability
for a civilization evolving
on a random planet have to
be for humanity,
be the only time it's ever happened.
What's the limit on that probability
from this new data that we've gotten a so
that we're the only time that civilization
has ever happened and we can do this
now. We can set an empirical limit on this
because we now know if I go back right
when Drake did his,
when Drake wrote down this equation,
that was the only term that was known. Now
these two terms have been nailed. Okay?
So that's a pretty large increase in your
understanding. Uh, for this equation,
it's only seven terms in it.
So it turns out the prop for us to be
the only time in cosmic history that is
civilization has arisen.
The probability would have to be
10 to the minus 22 or lower right?
One in 10 billion trillion.
If the probability for forming a
civilization on a planet, and you know,
nature's is going to set this right
through its evolutionary process,
if it's any larger than this
number, it's happened before. Okay?
That's a pretty small number.
Okay.
You don't have to work very hard in order
to get higher than one in 10 billion
trillion as if as long
as it's bigger than that,
we're not the first time there's been a
technological civilization. Okay? So, uh,
what that means.
So if you look at like famous pessimists
and time Ernst Mayer or Brandon Carter,
I won't go through this. These
are people who were like, no,
civilizations are really hard to make.
They never happen. They're really rare.
There are numbers are so much larger than
that pessimism line that there's been
tens of millions or trillions of
civilizations over cosmic space and time.
And the reason why it
was important to do this,
it was because what we really asking
is if you had a statistical ensemble of
alien civilizations, what
would their history be? Right?
They're all going to go through
what we're going through.
That's part of the argument is that you,
it's hard not to trigger an anthropocene
because a civilization is just a way of
taking energy, harvesting energy
from your planet and doing work.
Second Law of thermodynamics is kind of
gun to demand that you have some kind of
feedback. So, um, uh, you know,
with this work shows is that
it's really not hard. You know,
you don't have to work very hard in terms
of the probabilities to be end to end,
to end up with the conclusion that
there's been lots of histories. And so,
you know, doing thinking statistically
about, uh, anthropocenes, um,
is not a bad idea. So the Anthropocene,
it's happened before probably, right?
Which is a remarkable thing.
So that's what this idea that like,
we look at what's happening
with earth and you know,
we have this huge political debate.
Everybody's freaking out because it's
as if like, we're a teenager who do,
you know, going through our emotional
stuff and we kind of feel like, you know,
nobody's ever gone through this
before. And then they talk, yeah,
they get to an encounter
group or something and they
talk to others and realize
like, oh, everybody's gone through
this before. So by modeling this,
what can we figure out?
So the claim is we know enough about
planets and how they respond to forcing
meaning,
you know,
sermon dynamic driving to begin modeling
how any species will drive feedbacks on
their planet through energy
harvesting and civilization building.
So this is what I call a time with
tongue held politely and cheek,
the theoretical archeology
of Xo civilizations. Um,
so how do we do this?
Well,
but we're going to do is we're going
to do dynamical systems modeling.
We're going to set up equations for
a population interacting with its
environment. And this is a time
honored process in population biology.
Going all the way back to the Predator
prey model where you basically have an
equation for the bunnies and equation for
the wolves. And they're coupled, right?
Cause the, when the wolves eat the
bunnies, they get more wolf babies. Um,
but the more too many wolf babies
and there's no bunnies left to eat.
So you know, you can write down
these equations, solve them,
and you find these a oscillations, these,
uh, that are out of phase beautifully.
You know, the data really matched this
really well. So population biology,
you don't have to assume a lot about
population biology other than, you know,
you eat more resources, you
get more babies. That's,
that's the only assumption
I'm making in this,
these stimuli or the models that we're
making. And maybe you can say, okay,
well maybe on a life on another
planet doesn't do that. But you know,
that seems kind of fundamental
to what we think of as life.
Okay.
Um, so, you know, uh, when
we thought doing this,
what we imagined is we'd have some phase
space of planetary parameters, right?
Like energy consumption,
population feedback on the planet.
And what we imagine is when we run,
ran the models,
we'd get different kinds of a solution.
So like you could imagine you start off
with a very low population and you're
not using a lot of energy per person.
And what happens is as time goes on,
your technology increases,
you start using more energy in your
population goes up, you make more babies,
but eventually at some point
you're using so much energy,
you're feeding back on
the planet and your,
the trajectory of your
population will end up, you know,
heading in this direction and it gets
too large. And perhaps, you know,
the planet responds, you start having
instabilities, wild climate changes,
and then your population would,
you know, come way back down.
You basically collapse, right?
That's a collapsed trajectory.
Or You could have a
sustainability instructor.
We figure out how to deal with this and
you end up with some nice steady state
where your population is, is stable and
the or feedback on the planet is stable.
So this is what we were looking
to do when we built our models.
And it's very interesting to look
at the earth right now. This is the,
a world energy consumption
from 10,000 BC to now. Uh,
so that's our energy per capita.
This is co two concentration,
which is the planetary forcing and this
is global population. So those are those,
uh, those three things,
those three parameters for
the earth. And you see that,
yeah. Like we're, you know,
we're pretty much on a trajectory
for something enormous increase,
exponential increase in world population,
uh,
energy use and the feedback on the planet.
So what happens next generically?
So what we did is, you know,
these models, actually the paper
just came out recently. Um,
I won't go into the equations that we
use. These were actually, you know,
these were, as you guys all
understand, a toy model, right?
We tried to capture the essential of the
interaction between a population using
a planetary resource,
making more babies,
but having that planetary
resource feedback on the
state of the planet so that
you end up, you know, the planet drifts
away from where it was when you were born.
Okay. As a civilization. So here's
what the solutions look like.
So in these plots,
um,
green is the population of the
civilization and red you can think of is
planetary temperature.
And what we found broadly,
even in these simple models were
three classes of, of, um, of,
uh, trajectory. First was
what we call die off, right?
So here you see the die off
the population. You know,
a population rises very quickly because
it's consuming the planet's resource. Um,
the, the planet heats up the planet
to conditions on a plan to change. Um,
but, uh, so then the p the population
overshoots the planet's carrying capacity,
how many of that organism
the planet can sustain.
And then you get a big
drop in the number of, uh,
the population until you come to
some kind of Nice steady state,
but you do it at some cost so you
can lose weight in our models,
up to 70% of your population.
So imagine that everybody you knew,
seven out of every 10 people you knew,
uh, disappeared because of, uh, you know,
climate related disasters.
Um,
so it's not clear that a
civilization could survive
that. Maybe it could, but, um,
but at least,
you know,
the good news here was he did
get a steady state in the end.
There was also what we call the
sustainable or soft landing.
That was the really good news.
Yeah,
there's definitely solutions where you
change the planet, the, you know, read,
the temperature goes up, your population
goes up and your energy use goes up,
but you come to some steady state. So the
model's admitted that kind of solution.
But there was also the possibility of the,
of the collapse and there's, you know,
there's enough in there to be a
worrisome where the population rises,
the planet goes into a runaway,
essentially just like Venus went into a
runaway with a runaway greenhouse effect.
Why Venus is temperature
is now 800 degrees. Um,
so this is a different kind of runaway,
but at the same basic idea and your
population comes all the way down to
extinction. Now, whether or
not you actually are extinct,
what really matters is you can't maintain
your technological highly coupled,
you know,
networked civilization anymore.
So that's in some sense would
collapse means you also, interesting,
we found these oscillations
as well in there.
If you don't have the population rises
and falls and rises and falls. Um, so,
but either way.
So these were simple models,
but they gave us a hint that there
are generic classes of behavior in the
models. Okay? So this leads
us to, you know, eventually.
So this was a first cut at this.
What the next step is,
we're going to build
in real climate models,
we're going to build in the response of
different kinds of energy sources, right?
There's only going to be so
many kinds of energy sources.
A planet gives a young civilization,
you're going to have combustion,
maybe not fossil fuels, but if there's bio
mass, you can burn it, um, wind, solar,
etc. So we can build that into these and
really have, you know, much more, uh, uh,
uh,
physically accurate kinds of models.
And then we can run it for all kinds of
planets, planets that are close to there,
the inner edge of the habitable zone,
planets that are further out,
planets with that start with oxygen,
planets that start with less oxygen. Uh,
we can do all different kinds of things.
And from that,
what we're going to get is a predict
and we're going to make a prediction for
this average lifetime.
Now this really matters for us because
if the average lifetime of a civilization
is 200 years, we're hosed. Right?
Because what it means is
there's very little wiggle room.
You don't have a lot of leeway in the
bets you make as you try and navigate your
anthropocene. Almost nobody makes it,
right? On the other hand, if you're,
um, uh, tie, if your average
lifetime is 2 million years, yeah,
then you can make mistakes.
There's a lot of, you know,
you could experiment and still make it
through lots of civilizations managed to
make it through their
anthropocenes. So, you know,
this is the thing that we're headed
towards seeing and this itself sort of
frames what's happening to us now in
this, the sense that we are, you know,
one species out of many species that
have gone through this and, and you know,
we sort of need to think more broadly
about what are our choices in that case.
Okay. So more to the point
then we're almost done here.
The astrobiological perspective,
what it tells us that energy harvesting
species and their civilizations are
simply are simply something
that planets do. Okay.
We can't keep thinking of ourselves as
somehow special or unique. Um, we are,
uh, what the biosphere
is doing now, right? Um,
the biosphere are camp runs experiments,
planets with biospheres runs experiate
run experiments over and over again.
And we are simply one of
those right humans and then,
and are human beings and our civilization,
we're just part of nature. You know,
the, the biosphere has done
lots of interesting things.
It did invented grasslands. That was
a new idea at one point. Right? Um,
and then the grassland
spread across the planet,
change the planet's functioning
and invented dinosaurs.
It invented bluegreen bacteria.
We are just with the biosphere has
invented and is playing with now.
And there's no reason to think that we're
going to be what, um, uh, happens later.
So we're an expression of the planet now,
but do we continue to be an expression
of the planet? So one of these things,
right?
So this is very controversial.
I can get people really get
pissed off at me for this. Um,
what this means is climate
change is not our fault.
One of the things I want to push us away
from is this narrative we have of that
human beings are a plague on
the planet. We suck, right?
When it comes to climate change, we
don't have many stories, right? Many,
many sort of species wide,
planetary wide stories about ourselves.
Because as I said,
it's a new transition.
And the only story we have either
is it's not happening at all,
which is what you get from the climate
denialist or were terrible, were horrible,
were a virus on the planet.
And what I'm pointing out
here is that that's not true.
So what do I mean by this?
Before anybody gets really angry with me,
what I mean is that,
you know,
civilization since its beginning has
done what it has always looked for.
Energy sources that it can
power. It's, you know, buildings,
right? It's irrigation.
And we've been doing this since the end
of the, uh, the, the whole scene, right?
So when we found oil, it
wasn't like we were like, ah,
I was destroying the planet with
this substance. It was like, Oh,
this is brown guru and it's awesome.
You can heat your home,
you can build internal combustion engines.
It was great stuff.
We didn't know we were going to
trigger climate, right? It was,
it was an unintended consequence of the
adoption of a particular energy modality.
Right? Um, but now that we know,
if we don't do anything right now,
not doing anything about it would be
our fault. It would be our failure.
It would be our folly.
You,
it'll be why we end up in the garbage
heap of civilizations that couldn't manage
their transition to maturity.
Okay. So you know, it,
this doesn't absolve us
of the responsibility of
doing something about it,
given how important it is.
So what I'm trying to do here really
is change the narrative, right?
The anthropocene is not a
story of inherent human greed.
It is not a story of our unworthiness
on the planet and the plan is trying to
get rid of us.
In some sense.
It's a snotty story of us as being
a plague on the planet. Instead,
the Anthropocene is a story and that
we're just waking up to about planets and
their experiments,
right?
We didn't know about earth 4.5 billion
year history of life and coevolution
until very recently.
That is a new story for humanity.
And now we have to recognize
is how we fit into this, right?
Both because it's true and also it's the
story we need to understand to make it
through the, what were the climate
change we've triggered. So for me,
the true at lesson, so childhood
end, any science fans, right?
One of the great science fiction books,
uh,
the true lessons of the anthropocene are
that planets have rules and we need to
learn them, right? Planets
are machines, right?
And we need to understand
how they function in order
to re to put ourselves back
into them,
right?
Sustainability is really in some sense
and awakened planet in which both the
biosphere and the civilization
can flourish in entirely new ways.
There's a paper we wrote recently
where we looked at what would be the
thermodynamic properties of a planet
with a large scale civilization on it.
And the conclusions we came to,
there's gotta be some kind of cooperative,
you know,
relationship where we,
the civilization makes the biosphere even
more productive, not just for itself,
but for, you know, uh, you know,
not for the civilizations in,
but for the biosphere
is end. Um, it's really,
and this is about the
adoption of what you know,
has been called deep ecological values
were compassion and the identification
with life because we were
part of the biosphere.
We're not above it is a
kind of primary value. Okay.
And this is what's interesting for me.
It's actually the completion of Gaia,
right? Remember when I
talked about, you know,
one of the big scientific pushbacks
on the Gaia hypothesis was that it was
teleological. It had meaning
it had a direction, right?
And we know that evolution is blind. It's
blind until something like us shows up.
Once you get a technological civilization,
you're no longer blind, right? Uh,
the evolution is no longer blind.
We bring meaning we
bring direction to now,
to the evolution of the planet.
So this is idea that goes
way back of the know sphere.
I don't know if anybody's
ever heard of this. So, um,
there were two versions of
this, uh, Teilhard de Chardin,
which was a little bit more mystical. He
was, uh, uh, a scientist and a Jesuit, uh,
as well. Um, and he sort of thought
of it as the word, you know,
the world being in shrouded in
thought or in the world soul.
But there's also a verb Dansky Vladimir
for Dansky the great geochemists idea,
which was more like, yeah, the, you know,
once thought appears on the planet now,
just like there's a biosphere,
there's going to be, you know,
a sphere of thought around it. And, um,
the interesting thing was
shard Dan's version of this,
of the world being covered in thought,
what the more mystical one was,
the one that most people know about.
But of course, what happened is by then,
you know, if this is the great
place to talk about this,
we ended up building a no
sphere, right? I mean by mistake,
we didn't know we were going to
make a note of here, but like, yeah,
right now this room is
full of electromagnetic
radiations carrying thought,
right? I mean, everybody's cell phone
is picking up on the know sphere.
So you know, the idea of, um,
there being a directionality to the
biosphere is evolution. Once, you know,
a technological civilization shows
up, um, may actually be, you know,
now that the world is covered in the know
sphere, right? So this is, these are the,
you know, Internet links, um,
across the planet that may actually be a
natural part of the evolution. So, okay.
So with all of this, for me actually
leads, it's a story of hope, right?
So I did an Atlantic story about those
that, that, that study of, um, the,
the study we did of the different
possibilities of interaction between the
planet and it's a, at a planet and a
civilization, right? And all of a sudden,
I didn't Atlantic story on it and it got
picked up and everybody was focusing on
all the trajectories that led to death
and disaster. And I had to be like, Whoa,
wait a minute. One of the
trajectories with sustainability.
So like even though simple models
point after the fact, like, yeah,
you can do this, you know, I mean from
that simple perspective, you know,
if the question is, is sustainability
possible, the answer is yes,
it may be hard to achieve,
but at least it exists according to those
very simple models. Right. So the uh,
so I'm hopeful, you know,
so in its context, the, um,
the, in the cosmic context,
in some sense the
Anthropocene doesn't happen.
It's not a story with villains in it.
Right.
As much as I am very angry at the
people who promote climate denial,
they're not villains,
they're folly.
They are the agent of our folly that
will lead us to not reaching our own
potential. Okay. But from the biosphere's
perspective, you know, there's,
there's planets have histories,
they have trajectories and hopefully
you can manage to get yourself on a good
one. Oh. And vote out the people
who are keeping you holding back.
So it's a story about winners and losers
and re essentially what I want to say
is that we are cosmic teenagers and
that we need to grow up. So, you know,
I think someone has done it. So why
can't we, and I'll end with this.
This is a picture of Bill Nye came
to the University of Rochester. Um,
and he gave a talk and I was amazed.
I mean, I, you know, I grew up,
I knew bill Nye when I was a graduate
student, you know, even in Seattle,
but I didn't realize like
the, uh, how much the student,
how much the love the students
had from it. And you know,
he was there talking about climate
change, how students can, you know,
solve climate change. And these guys
were all there and they were like, here,
I never saw so much optimism
and hope, you know, so like,
I absolutely think this is a, you
know, a, a solvable problem on,
but we have the wrong story
and can we change that story?
We're going to kind of be, our options
will be limited. So I thank you very much.
I really appreciate
your time and listening.
Okay.
I don't know if anybody wants to ask
questions, but yes. Uh, I'm curious about
one part of one slide possibility of a
civilization once you're in the habitable
zone,
unbelief was tend to the negative 22,
not the possibility that the, that if
we don't know what the actual problem
bloody yes, right. Yeah. Right.
The limit, the pessimism limited.
If it's below that, then we're the only
time it's ever happened. Right. If it's,
if nature's choice for those,
that probability is above that,
then there's been lots of wondering
if though, if you could expand,
we basically said, well, that's a really
small number. Right. And absolute value.
It's very small. Right. So therefore I'm
going to bet that it's larger. Right.
That doesn't seem very satisfying to me.
There are lots of numbers in nature of
the turnout to actually be very small,
smaller than humans would have
desks and there was a tune up.
I'd be me hugely bigger than humans would
have guessed because we tend to anchor.
Yeah. Yeah. It was
around one. Right. Uh, so
yes. No, that's a good point. That's why
the history of this debate is important,
right? That number doesn't appear out
of nowhere. Yeah. Well I mean, you know,
it comes from that number doesn't
appear out of context. Right?
So there have been over the years, over
50 years, people trying to approximate,
you know,
do some kind of calculation that shows
them what this probability should be.
And the best of them all is what's the,
what's called the hard step
model by Brandon Carter.
And that's at the heart step
models now become, you know,
actually essential because
you could actually calculate
probabilities out of it.
And what he did, it's typical
brilliant reasoning, you know, uh,
where he just basically like he looked
at the history of the earth and said,
oh look, the earth is only going to be
habitable for another billion or half,
maybe a half billion years.
And intelligence didn't show
up until the end. Right?
So therefore it must be
intelligence must be hard. Right?
And so then he came up with this idea,
there must have been a bunch of hard
steps that evolution had to go through.
So from that he was able to
use the correct probability,
distributions, et cetera.
And he gets, you know, he estimated
that there were 10 hard steps, right?
And so then he calculated out of that
what that probability had to be there for.
And he got 10 to the 20 and he
concluded in that there's actually,
I put that quote in there,
I'd have to switch all the
back. But he basically said,
based on this 10 to the minus 20,
sorry, you said, based on this,
we are the only time that civilization
has ever formed in the history of
universe. Now you do that. You've got
data, you put it in and you find it. No,
actually in your mind, and you
know, Brandon Carter's model,
there's a hundred civilizations that have
occurred across cosmic history, right?
And we now know that there are not no,
but now the idea is
there's not 10 heart steps.
There's maybe only five heart steps.
Now, again, this is all still, you know,
controversial, you know, um, we don't
even know if the hard step model is true,
but it's the best one that we
have that actually gives us a law,
allows us to do something, uh,
articulate something numerically.
And with five hard steps,
you're down to a 10 to the minus 15,
which means there would have
been 10 million, um, uh, uh,
civilizations over cosmic
space and time. So, you know,
when you look at the history
and what the, uh, you know,
almost no pessimists historically
has gone that far down. So, so if,
if they were right, there would still
have been lots of civilizations.
So hope that helps. Yeah. I mean, just,
it's still, of course we are in the realm,
you know, until we actually find one, you
know, you're going to be dealing with,
but the best science we have, the history
of this field, people, you know, the,
the best estimations makes
that number very, very small.
Yes. You're walking too much
Saifai lately. Excellent.
Um, so I'd watch the expanse of
law fe best show ever, right?
Yeah. The chances of humans
actually getting to the,
to a full solar system.
Why,
what I argue often is that's the prize.
If we make it through climate change,
that's what's waiting for us. I
mean, I really do believe, you know,
interstellar travel where I'm actually
right now writing a paper about the Fermi
paradox. Interstellar travel
may be very, very difficult,
but interplanetary travel,
especially if you have some kind of fusion
engine will not be. And, um, I think,
you know, in another 200
years, like, who knows, right?
There are obviously very formidable
problems, but I'm hopeful, you know,
I'm a techno optimist and I'm hopeful
that, you know, uh, you know, in 200,
300 years there can be a
lot of people, uh, you know,
that this is the solar system. There's a
lot of nooks and crannies that, you know,
human beings can, um, and, and you know,
people say, well, why would they do that?
Because, you know, basically everybody
wants to their own society. This is,
you know what,
I love the expanse gets right.
There's going to be
Mormons in space for sure.
So they can create their own
space settlement and live
Mormon light and there'll
be the odd thousand versions
of that. So, um, I think, yeah,
if we can just figure out climate
change and they're related, right?
Because you're not gonna be
able to, in order to, you know,
to solve climate change,
you have to think like a planet.
But in order to have a self sustaining,
you know,
whatever bubbles civilization with a
million people and that you also have to
understand how planets think and build
a, you know, smaller version of it.
That's why the expanse gets so well.
And you know, the scene after the, uh,
after co what does the Callisto or
Ganymede after the station on Ganymede
collapses and, and what's his name,
pack recognizes that, oh my God,
the whole infer, the ecological
infrastructure of the
thing is going to collapse.
Now does anybody watching the expanse
or people watching the expanse?
It's really good. I really got it. And
the books are super awesome too. Yes.
I'm curious what your thoughts are,
but yeah.
Well, first of all, I want to,
you know, there's two things,
there's two ways to think
about the Fermi paradox.
The first one is the idea that, um, you
know, we haven't found anybody, you know,
we've been searching the stars for
signals. We haven't found anything.
And that's just not true.
I mean,
there's never really been a
large scale steady effort, right?
Said he's never been really fully funded.
NASA,
NASA started to do a large study search
and then because of William Proxmire it
stopped it. So as Jill
tarter says, if, you know,
if the parameter space we have to search
for looking for aliens is the ocean,
we have looked at assemble so far,
so saying that we haven't found anything,
it's just it, you know, that's
just not scientifically valid.
So we barely begun to look not just in
radio but all the other possibilities. Um,
but if you asking about the
part of the frame parsonage,
why haven't we been visited? Like why
isn't it, why don't we have evidence for,
you know,
a civilization,
the colonization part that actually we
find in our paper is more of a problem.
And so the solution to that,
uh,
right now in the paper I
think we're leaning towards
is that interstellar travel
is really hard. You don't get
many successful colonization
missions. You know,
obviously there's some assumptions here,
uh, in this. Um, but again, you know,
we just did a paper a recently where with,
I did it with Gavin Schmidt from Goddard
Institute space studies where we just
asked how would you,
this was amazing question.
How would you know whether there was a
previous technological civilization on
earth 20 million years ago? We actually
couldn't, right. There's really, you know,
and there's would not be much left
over there would certainly after by 20
million years, the surface has
been completely re, uh, re scoured.
So you're not going to find ruins already.
You'd have to look for isotopic
anomalies or something, which may be,
well that's the thing. No, no,
he's right. Actually that's the,
that that is exactly what
you'd have to look for.
So when it comes to just the earth itself,
the earth has been weathered so heavily
in subducted that it would be hard.
And so you know,
there's been a couple papers on exactly
that about that the best place to look
for this is going to be on other bodies.
So yes.
Related to that,
I think the seems to be the one part
where you really do have to n equals one
problem is what you were
talking about the sphere, right?
Cause you have all this evidence
for what happened to previously.
We have all these other planets out
there, right? But in a lot of this stuff,
especially with the Fermi paradox,
it seems to me falls prey to
this n equals one problem. We,
you're sort of assuming that intelligent
or the civilization is going to do is
going to behave like we expect.
Well I think that's why, that's why my
models tried to have no sociology in them.
It's the only assumption was a
civilization consumes energy to do work.
That's like the only assumption in there.
So I don't need to know sphere
or anything else, it's just that
make assumptions about what
sort of energy production.
Uh,
there's only,
there's only so much kind of energy
production you're going to get as a young
civilization, right? The planet's
only going to afford you. You know,
if you have z raise,
I'm like super hyper high tide technology,
well then you're already passed this
anyway, right? If you have warp drives,
you're not really worrying about Europe.
You know, you've probably gotten,
your science is so far
advanced that you're the buyer,
you probably have already
gone through this.
But if you're a young civilization like
ours, you've got bio mass or you've got,
you've got, you can burn things. There's
wind, there's solar, there's nuclear,
um, and there's, um, geothermal,
right? And that's pretty
much it. It's, you can't,
you know,
maybe if I'm some weird planet,
you could have like super
magnetic fields or something.
So what you can do for each one of those,
you can evaluate what the thermodynamic
effect of using it large scale.
So for example,
there was a paper done a few years ago
where they looked at trying to extract
from wind energy,
the power,
what would the consequences be of power
powering our civilization via wind.
And what you find is because of turbulence
downstream, you end up with, you know,
the equivalent of like two
degrees of warming. So,
which is important because what it means
is you can't power a civilization like
this and have no impact the, and
so this goes back to nature, right?
The idea that there's going to be,
we're going to be able to
return to pristine nature,
not with us on the planet,
right? You can have lower impact
that you're going to have to be,
you're gonna have to figure
out what kind of impacts.
But the idea that you can have no impact
is just doesn't make sense. So yeah,
you can evaluate for every different
kind of energy source, you know,
at least make a cut at what the impact is.
Assumption you're making is that
civilization requires energy.
And that seems to be, that's something
good. I think a lot of seems to,
we have a very economist
way of doing things. Um,
well I don't see that's a feminist. I
don't understand it. If a civil as they,
I mean, you know, in some
sense by definition and
industrial civilization know.
I mean Rome, I'm not interested in
Rome, right. Because Rome wouldn't have,
Rome wouldn't push it's planet into
an anthropocene. Right. So you know,
if a civilization decides to get up to
rums level and never gets farther, yeah.
That sort of out of the,
you know,
you're right that that's
not what I'm talking about.
But if you build an industrial civil,
if you start heart,
it's all about the energy per capita,
right?
So right now all of us
have the equivalent of,
of just from our home when we go
home and our plugs, 50 servants,
that's the energy equivalent 50 servants.
And that doesn't say anything about
your transportation or whatever.
So once a species gets to the point where
the per capita energy use becomes more
than one individual's
worth per individual,
that's when you're going to
start feeding back. So that,
that's the only assumption.
If they start doing that,
then they sort of fall into the category
that I'm interested in. And then he got,
I don't really care about sociology or
whether they develop a no sphere or not.
Maybe they do,
maybe they don't.
It's just that they're harvesting
energy to do the work of building their
civilization.
Yeah.
So do you think that the current home
where basically as a matter of marketing
that we have the tools,
sort of the guidance, the,
there'll be neat to get through it if
we all just somehow add it together?
Yeah, I think that's, you know, there was,
I was just reading recently about a study
that sort of showed a super detailed
study that you could actually power,
you know, the world with renewables,
with wind, water, you know,
but the thing, but you know,
it's always a really detailed plan for
doing it. Of course it required this,
you know, sort of, you know,
World War Two Manhattan style
project for the entire world.
And so that's going to be hard. But
in terms of like technologically, man,
unleash the innovation, let us,
that's one of this, you know,
when I go out and I'm talking to people,
one things I'm saying is like, you know,
on one level climate change shows how
awesome we are, right? I mean, you know,
we've changed the atmosphere
of an entire planet.
That's pretty good for a bunch of
hair hairless monkeys, you know? Um,
and now the question is,
are we smart enough to innovate our way
into some kind of sustainable version of
it? So it's, you know, so it's not just
marketing though. It's deeper than that.
It's myth, right? Human beings always need
stories. I don't, you know, somebody said,
you know, stories where the first
technology and the problem is here,
we have all of these from the, you
know, long history of humanity.
We have these myths about
the coming of age, about
marriage, about old age. Um, uh,
but we don't have any. And we have
creation myths. But climate change,
we don't have a myth for, because it's
new. We've never done this before.
And so what I'm suggesting is,
is that, you know, a first,
it's not like this alone
is gonna solve anything,
but if we don't change the narrative,
we are stuck arguing with people about
whether we change the climate or not.
From this perspective, that
question just disappears. It's like,
of course you change the climate.
You built a civilization that consumes
a quarter of the entire biospheres
productive capacity, you know, what did
you expect? So I think it just, you know,
one of the things in revolutions in
scientific revolutions that happen is that
the old questions,
when you go through a paradigm shift,
it's not that the old
questions are answered,
the whole question just don't
even become meaningful anymore.
People ask a new set of questions and
that's at least what I'm proposing with
this.
Yeah. This might try it a
little bit more philosophical,
although they're clearly
philosophical ideas. Yeah. Um,
you mentioned that you're an optimist.
And piggy backing on the question
about marketing, I'm sort of,
my worry is that there is not in fact
present in human thinking, the idea that
humanity is in fact a single species.
Yeah. We can sort of think
about this as a collaborator,
as a truly collaborative project.
And I think one way to be pessimistic
about this as to worry about factum
minimization and whatnot.
Do you have thoughts that make you
more optimistic on that? Is it sort of,
and I'm not saying that blind faith
would be unreasonable perhaps. Yeah.
Yeah. I mean it's gotten us through
a lot. Um, but no, actually, so,
so I think when you look across species,
you know,
I know I feel confident in my bones
that there've been other civilizations,
right?
You know,
scientifically I can only go forward
the probabilities that this has happened
before.
And what I imagine is the ones that
make it have either the evolutionary
background to have the right
kinds of behaviors, maybe,
maybe hive minds much easier if you're
a hive mind to make it through this then
if you're a, the kind of thing that we
are. But the other possibility is that,
you know, you evolve
under pressure, right?
Selective pressure is what
determines a evolution. And you know,
perhaps this is the agent by
which we start to, uh, create
new behaviors. You know,
the Paris accord was weak,
but the Paris accord was also remarkable
in those sense that we've got every
country to sign this thing.
So that was the beginning and then we
took a step back. Um, but you know,
so I think, you know, this is
this May, the cl, you know,
the anthropocenes maybe the agent for
some kinds of species, perhaps like ours,
to develop new evolutionary behaviors
that allow them to get through and
everything. You make it through.
You know, it's weird like, Hey,
if I put my hat on as a dad, I'm like,
Oh my God, we've got to make it through.
But if I put my hat on as an
astronomer, I'm like, yes,
I'll make it through some don't, you know?
Yeah. Nothing special about us. Okay.
All right. Well, thank you very much.
Uh, I really appreciate you guys
[inaudible].